We've seen direct variation and we've seen inverse variation, but these two
don't have to be separate. There are times when the quantities can vary jointly.
In other words, we'll have more than just two amounts related to each other. An
example of this would be simple interest that accrues over time. Simple interest
is equal to the principal amount we start with times the interest rate. The
amount of interest that accumulates in one year is dependent, or varies directly
with these other two values. If the principal amount were to go up, our interest
would also go up. Likewise, if we increase the interest rate, our interest would
go up as well. So this is a case of joint variation. Because simple interest
varies directly with both the principal amount and the interest rate, we could
set up a proportion like this. The principal amount and the interest rate
associated with our first interest would appear directly across from it. So if
we had any five of these quantities, we could solve for the remaining one, or
the one that's left out. Let's see if you can use this idea of joint variation
to solve a different problem.